[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to the data
science hangout hope everyone's having a
great week
for anybody joining us for their very
first time today welcome
this is actually our second to last data
science hangout for 2022
so thank you to everybody who's been
with us this whole year as well this is
an open space for the whole data science
Community to connect and chat about data
Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to learn about what's
going on in the world of data science
and getting a view into different
Industries and use cases
we share the recordings of these
sessions to our posit YouTube so you can
always go back and re-watch or find
helpful resources
and sorry I am three weeks behind but I
will do that this week
and update them
together we're all dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment for everybody no
matter what industry or background or
experience you have we want to hear from
everybody
so there's always three ways that you
can ask questions
and also to provide your own perspective
it doesn't have to be just a question
you can jump in by raising your hand on
zoom and I'll be on the lookout there
you could put questions into the zoom
chat and feel free to put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it out
loud instead
maybe you're in a coffee shop or
something
and then third we also have a slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
I will mention too if you want to
connect with people after the fact we do
have our LinkedIn group for the hangout
I know right now not too much
conversation goes on in there but would
love to create that space where you can
easily find each other
you do have to manually turn on
notifications in that group so that
might be part of it
but I am so happy to be joined by my
co-host for today and our friend from
the data science hangout Javier
orica.com lead machine learning engineer
at centene now congrats on the new role
and Javier I'd love to have you uh let
me reintroduce yourself because I know
you've met a lot of us from from past
weeks as well and share a little bit
about your role and and the company now
and maybe something you like to do in
your free time too thanks Rachel yeah
and it's great to be here
um this has been I've told many people
this I really do mean it this has been
like my favorite standing meeting for
the last year and a half or so so I feel
like you've been doing an awesome job
Rachel
um and I love this kind of like platform
for knowledge sharing and whatnot but
yeah my name is Javier oracadaku
um
I've you know been around the finance
corporate finance and sort of data
science world for
um
like 15 plus years
um
I've
I spent a lot of my career in Consulting
doing different types of financial
modeling around evaluation work
um different types of like economic
studies like
um you know economic obsolescent studies
functional obsolescent studies some tax
optimization type work
um and in those days I was mostly using
Excel
um we would do some you know SQL or SQL
work but it was pretty minimal uh
whenever we were doing that I was
actually using Microsoft Access
um I feel like that's not really a tool
used nowadays but at least at the time
when we were working with you know
hundreds of thousands or millions of
Records
um it was much easier to do the same
types of group buys and sort of
summations that we were doing in Excel
just you know and for bigger data using
access so
um
I went back to grad school I really
wanted to get into data science it was
kind of a buzzword I was reading all
about Predictive Analytics Without
Really knowing what it was or what it
meant but it excited me
um I wanted to really get my hands on
that and understand how I can take sort
of the
forecasting or you know modeling skills
that I had sort of taking it to the next
level so that I could start trying to
automate some of my work or some of the
reporting that I'm doing so I went back
to grad school
uh and yeah when I got out of grad
school I joined centene
I was with them for about two years
um I quit to go work for an e-commerce
startup for about a year and I just
recently returned to centene
um I'm on week two in a new org so bear
with me if I can't answer all the
questions about my work but
um
yeah here at centene I'm a lead machine
learning engineer I'm part of a scrum
team that uh is a joint effort with
different data scientists and data
engineers and were
partnering with our business
stakeholders and really taking these
like high Roi you know predictive
modeling Concepts and putting them into
production
um
yeah something I like to do for fun I
love playing board games
um I feel like I spend way too much of
my free time reading about developments
in the r world or you know python
developments
um I mean I enjoy it a lot of times I'm
just reading about the stuff not really
even you know applying it through code
or anything just trying to keep up with
all the trends that are happening
um
and yeah that's a little bit about me
thank you I have to ask what's your
favorite board game
in terms of being able to explain it to
friends or play it quickly I love
Splendor it's a card game it's uh two to
four players it's especially if the
people you're playing you know playing
it with have have had a few repetitions
it's a really fun kind of quick game
um
yeah it's great
thank you I'll have to check it out okay
I see the questions are coming in right
off the bat so you don't even need me
for the first minute here so somebody
asked anonymously
um when is when is machine learning
appropriate or necessary
okay so I
I come from a heavy Excel background so
I will sort of caveat my response by
saying
um
you know My Views might be a little more
nuanced than someone maybe coming from
like a CS background or someone
especially nowadays I mean I feel like
people graduating from undergrad and
going into Master's programs or like
diving straight into machine learning
which is awesome
um but I will say there is a lot of
you know reporting or kpi creation or
you know evaluating different kpis that
doesn't require
um machine learning and that is also
high value because it helps the business
track
whether or not some different product or
you know program is successful
um
where
I mean anytime
like machine learning can be used for
inference or prediction
um and I feel like
both kind of sides of this machine
learning equation add a lot of value for
different reasons
um when it gets to
you know prediction
um
I'd say this is where you really want to
make an intervention of some sort or you
know you you want to focus on a subset
of your overall customers or consumers
and either give value to them or help
the business Maybe by
um
you know mitigating the risk of churn
um there's just a lot of reasons I'm not
giving a great answer here but and I'm
happy to give more detail but if that
individual's you know if you're willing
to submit another anonymous question or
something I'm happy to dive further into
that
thank you and Bill I see you just put a
question into the chat do you want to
jump in next
I'll start reading and then you can jump
in if you want to add any context to but
Bill asked how big is your team at your
new
wait hold on how big is your team at
your new job and maybe break down by
roles
um use of R and or python is more used
in ex hold on sorry I need to no button
a little bit or do people still try to
develop new or run old models using
Excel
yeah that's a good question
oh bill was that you
can you hear me yes you can yeah so so I
asked because
um I work at a biotech company and some
guy was uh giving his presentation of
this fancy model about drug pricing
prediction all this kind of stuff and I
said oh well you know do you use sasa's
Mo you know add-on product that costs
Mega dollars or or what do you what's
this done in and he said he said VBA and
I said I didn't quite understand because
you know he has an accent to me an
American as a VBA I said yeah it's a VBA
so anyway that's one of the things that
prompts uh what you're talking as well
as your prior
um uh discussion of your experience so
yeah so I mean that's a really good
question and again like my Excel
experience is nuanced
um I would say
99
let's say 90 of people using Excel are
using it as a big calculator everything
sort of ad hoc just sort of thrown
together maybe they're using pivot
tables but there's no real like modeling
workflow to their Excel work
um then you have maybe 10 of people that
are actually using Excel in a more
advanced way where they actually have
like you know an inputs and assumptions
tab which is just straight up text
explaining the purpose of the model and
what's going to happen in the in the
subsequent tabs
um and you kind of go from like your
records maybe one tab is just you know
straight tabular data you know names or
identifiers on the left and then a bunch
of different calculations on the right
and then going sort of left to right or
right to left you get to summaries that
are actually consumable for leaders in
the business
um and then there's probably like point
one percent of excel users that
are using it in a pretty Advanced way
whether it's you know like logistic
regressions or different types of linear
regressions
um you could do a lot of Monte Carlo
simulations there's a lot you can do I
mean when you start feeling like the GUI
itself isn't you know uh sufficient
enough
VBA or Visual Basic it's uh you know
programming language that
plays hand in hand with Excel and you
can actually do a lot with sort of
automating the workflow or the the
sequence of calculations or group buys
or whatever with VBA in Excel
I will say that is not typical of excel
users
it's also very limiting because with
more sort of Open Source
programming languages
not only with the languages themselves
but with all the libraries that are
available for these languages
um there's just so much development
happening on a daily basis and I I feel
like
for what you described
while it could potentially be done in
VBA
if you wanted to scale something that is
consumable for that business
organization or for other data analysts
or business analysts
you know at your company you probably
want to take the results of those
findings and push them into some data
warehouse or something that again is is
consumable to a larger organization and
in order to do that you need to figure
out okay well where is this code going
to live when is it going to be refreshed
is it going to be retrained how is it
going to be retrained you know what
systems are going to help us take this
overall logic and put it into a
production setting so that me as a data
analyst or a business leader can just
access some table on a data warehouse
and see the results I want to see very
quickly and know that they're updated at
any point in time
um that's where I feel like moving
towards
you know python or R kind of opens your
world of possibilities within the
context of like
Automation and machine learning I don't
know Bill does that answer your question
oh we don't hear you
uh
yeah yes it's
sorta kinda so again like I don't know
how big your your company is and I don't
know uh yeah you know so there's always
challenges like one of those challenges
you're talking about scaling and having
an infrastructure well a lot of
companies I'm familiar with that means
that you bump into
I.T and I.T and I also work in a
regulated industry and so it seems to be
like the regulator like they like to
they like to squash
um the kind of thing that you're talking
about even though it totally makes sense
to me and other people in the business
thing but then they're worried about
people having too much access to stuff
um I I find myself I find myself I find
myself rambling and I think the main
thing I wanted to know I just wanted to
know uh so you come back to this new
place do you have the tools to to do
this and are you making an impact or are
other people still like on their own
computers doing Excel and being hap
being happy and and being able to
present a report every every few weeks
of somebody who's passed them on the
back and says hey great okay so we're
there's like 70 plus thousand people at
centene it's a massive company
um I design I mean there I think they're
like a fortune 26 company
you really don't know the name because
by Design compared to the other health
insurance carriers
um
they wanted to have kind of a portfolio
management company and then
you know each state that we operate in
sort of has their own brand
um with that the majority of our
analysts and probably data scientists
and biostatisticians work for the brands
doing kind of plan specific analyzes
um I where I'm at now is kind of the
corporate group
um and we
partner with
stakeholders in the business at
different operating units or we partner
with
you know ideas idea generators that that
want that have a business use case that
can be scaled for the entirety of our
business not just one plan
um from that perspective
you know I I think there are some
differences between like
like I roll up into it now and I
definitely sympathize with you because
when I was previously at centene I was
actually working for Health Net which is
one of these State plans and there's a
lot that I wanted to do to put into
production but there's so much sensitive
data in production that
corporate sort of
um
you know helps manage the whole process
of getting a model into an actual
production setting a model or a shiny
app or something like this so you can do
a lot as a data scientist and a business
org
you know in the development and test
environments that are out there but when
it gets to production then there is
somewhat of a handoff in
um ownership if you will or
responsibility of getting that code into
a production setting
um and that's where there's a kind of
hand or you know handshake or pass off
between sort of the business scientists
and then you know the um
the corporate data science team
and there's there's probably so 70 000
people
we have an ongoing chat of about 500
data analysts and data scientists
there's you know different again like
clinical informatics people and
biostatisticians and there's a lot of
very interesting Niche work going on
um but the one thing that I really love
about this organization is the the
knowledge sharing
um there's a lot of that that happens
organically
um
you know I love that
there's not a lot of shame in asking
questions it's encouraged if you don't
know something go ahead and ask it
um I have you know no shame when it
comes to asking people for help but at
the same time
you know on the flip side of this
if someone comes to me I'm definitely
going to try and make some time to help
this individual with their problems
um
just to kind of balance it all out
absolutely and I I always love seeing in
the chat everybody kind of commenting in
on what they're experiencing in their
organizations to and Nessa love to hear
what you're doing there too that's great
um I see Eric you had asked a question a
bit earlier in the chat do you want to
jump in yeah um it's great to have you
Javier on on the hangout
um as part of a part of my organization
and the group I'm in I would say we're
kind of growing into getting Ai and ml
more entrench in some of our work but
leadership will hear all the positive
buzz from various Tech sectors and they
say we want to use ml but what I'm
running your perspective on if you could
share any insights is how do you
approach finding best use cases to use
the algorithms without going down
potentially dead ends or making sure
that leadership understands that NL is
not going to magically be the perfect
solution for every use case
I don't know if that makes sense yeah
for sure
um I would say and I'm new to this
process because again I was sort of a ad
you know a one-off data scientist and a
business org prior to
joining this corporate team
um
and so I'm still learning about all our
systems and everything that that's
available but
one aspect of this team's work which
um you know I think could be applicable
that other companies is to have a really
structured sort of intake process for
people that have new
you know everyone's excited about ML and
AI but there should be some sort of
detailed or
like an educated guesstimate of Roi for
the projects that people want to put in
and that's really hard to do
um even for experienced you know
developers and data scientists it's so I
would say
if you don't already have some type of
like
you know intake process or something
like this where
your business stakeholders that might
have ideas can come in and request
um some type of like company-wide Eli
lillywhide you know
project that
as part of that submission
um or as part of a conversation that
your team has with them is to really try
and like quantitatively determine what
the benefit would be
um I mean I think that is going to go
really far away I'm still learning about
our whole intake process but
a lot of My Health Net peers
um
you know now that they know that I'm
back or like hey can we partner with
this can we partner with this and I'm
like there is sort of a like we are
trying to prioritize the highest Roi
um you know projects and there is an
official intake program so I'm pretty
much just sending them information on
hey here's here's the forums you know
please populate them and
um
yeah that that seems to have helped a
lot or helped this team scale out their
models a lot
and and prioritize Which models to
actually put into production
I hope that answers your question Eric
oh that's that's very helpful and there
are certainly Pockets where we do have
some of those things in place from our
general project ideas or more General
initiatives but yeah it's it's growing
the ml case in certain parts of the
business where that just has not been
implemented at all we're trying to find
the best ways but that's good advice uh
nonetheless yeah
I really like the oh you go ahead
I was just going to tell Eric because he
for those of you who don't know he has
an awesome podcast and he runs the shiny
developer series another amazing you
know resource
um I just wanted to comment that
um now that I'm in this corporate team
there's a lot that like
some of my old colleagues that I'd work
with closely I wouldn't actually
recommend them to submit you know a use
case for us because their problem is so
like brand or you know problem specific
like it's not something that can be
scaled
um
I noticed
there were
I I'm still like taking trainings and
stuff so excuse me for you know not
knowing like everything about the org
now but before I left shiny was becoming
really popular people loved seeing what
a shiny app could do
um I would say
that I'm like actively sort of
telling people who have no R experience
but have heavy Excel experience for
certain dashboards they Envision in
shiny that maybe a power bi or just
Excel dashboard is the way to go because
they'll be able to get what they want
much faster
um you know the overhead to sort of
Design This is
like making their project a shiny app is
almost unnecessary from what I see
um so I mean I love shiny but I I think
even for like Finance orgs or actuaries
or you know people that are doing a lot
of maybe heavier analysis in Excel
um
where you want to convince them that hey
shiny might be the best place for you is
when they're trying to get into scenario
testing or like machine learning or like
basic things you know they've got two
million records that they've somehow
hodgepodged together in Excel but you
know when they drop when they make
different selections in an Excel
dashboard it takes three minutes for the
dashboard to re-render like that's a
good use case to put it into shiny
because that three minutes is now all of
a sudden two seconds
um that's when I'm like a very big
outspoken advocate of hey you should
have some dedicated resources on your
team either
learn about R and shiny
um or uh you know if this is a problem
that you think could be scaled for the
entire business then uh consider
submitting some type of intake intake
form so that other other business units
could also make use of this type of
shiny app
a lot of great questions coming in and I
really like the way you describe the the
open culture at suntean and it being
okay to ask questions it also get like
providing that time back to people and
and being so willing to help I see Libby
you had asked a question about the
community
at centene I believe do you want to jump
in
yeah I would love to
um so I hope I'm not remembering
incorrectly but I'm pretty sure you had
a hand in starting our user group at
centene when you were there previously
um and so I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about that because
that's a difficult task and you have to
like recruit people and getting people
to meet up and help each other and stuff
like that
um it's really challenging so I was
hoping you could give us a little bit of
a rundown on how that happened yeah
thanks Louis and great to see you so
um
there was I sort of piggybacked from a
general data science Community chat that
we had at the company
um and you know there were several
hundred people on this of varying
backgrounds and expert expertise levels
and so
there was a lot of conversation
happening there was already a python
group that was meeting I think every
other month so
me coming in like three weeks after I
started I got really excited about the
possibility of potentially creating
something similar for R uh our users
and so I think it started by just
reaching trying to figure out who owns
that already existing data science chat
and see if they could help support the
idea of creating a python or sorry an R
User Group you know something to me
once a month or once every two months
um because I think at the larger
companies getting that type of like top
level level kind of executive uh you
know stamp of approval and support can
go a long way especially if that
individual is part of the already
existing it or data science function
um and so
yeah at the time I created a Blog down
site for those of you who are familiar
with our markdown blog down is just kind
of a you know it's a package that allows
you to create static websites uh static
blogs with our markdown
um you know distill is a very similar
concept
um
quarto now with quarto you can do the
same thing creating websites
um and I yeah I love the syntax of quota
but anyway uh so we started I think what
started is like 13 users the first month
one of them is at our studio now I don't
know if he's on this chat uh Dave
grindwald
he might be here anyway uh hey Dave hey
I'm here hey thanks Tom how are you yeah
so David great
um Dave taught me shiny I tell him this
often I owe like my current career to
Dave because it made shiny itself made
me such a better overall programmer and
the way I think about functions and
recycling code like seriously thank you
Dave but
um yeah what started with about 13 users
uh within a few months jumped to about
100 125 you know monthly users that were
on this are specific uh monthly Meetup
um so we had a really great time you
know the Partnerships we had with posit
we were able to get uh some people to
come in and do workshops as well
um it was yeah it was it was just a
great way
everyone was so collaborative and it was
such a great way to see the excitement
around what you could do with like all
things are
um and even python like how can we tap
into
this these robust like you know python
libraries or Python and like we had
reticulate sessions where it was you
know a co-branded python R kind of
Workshop where we're looking at ways in
which we can actually
um
you know communicate between teams of
different languages a lot easier and so
anyway I I had a great experience with
it yeah
that's awesome thank you
thank you I see a few anonymous
questions I want to make sure to jump
over to as well and one was how do you
navigate stakeholder uncertainty and
incongruent project valuations for data
science projects first more traditional
engineering projects
that's a good question I
I don't know about traditional
engineering projects to be honest
um
I don't feel like I've been surrounded
by that world enough to to like speak
you know and yeah I I really don't know
when it comes to the data science
projects
um
at least at the point
I feel like where we are now
um
you know just really careful objective
kind of unbiased review of what the ask
is
um has been very helpful
um being able to like in however way you
want to do this like it doesn't need to
be just a dollar value like what savings
are we gonna have or what benefits are
we going to have you can kind of
score the different potential projects
coming in
um where at least project to project you
can prioritize which one is going to
have the most impact for the business or
you know an impact can even be measured
differently like which one's going to
have the most short-term impact what's
the what's the best project for
long-term impact I mean maybe all these
things could be different weights for
your scoring of these different projects
to understand what your team should
focus on
um but yeah I would say trying to
develop some system or framework where
you can actually
um like
help prioritize or rate the importance
of these new projects is really helpful
thank you and there's actually a
follow-up anonymous question to that too
and I'm gonna start just copying the
slido questions into the chat so people
can see them as I'm reading them as well
but the question was what does an Roi
timeline look like for most projects are
you working on things that come to life
years down the line
I actually do not know yet but I would
say a lot of these probably come to life
within the same year
yeah
I don't think they're like I don't think
the planning is so far ahead there are
larger I.T goals and things in motion
that could be like a multi-year type of
transition I just don't work on those
types of projects the focus of my work
is more data science specific
I see you asked a question in the chat
do you want to jump in live
okay can you guys hear me okay yes
awesome so yeah I guess for me it's more
like I can relate in a heavy way to the
one-off kind of background to what
you're doing and so a lot of the
obstacles I've always tried to overcome
is just kind of applying you know my
particular skill set in programming to
um to the work that I'm doing but
having more of like a medical and Epi
background has been a huge benefit to me
but is something that is often like Lost
in Translation to to leadership or two
did we lose Jared or was that me no I
think we lost him
Jared you froze
well I'm sure Jared will be back in a
few seconds did you get uh the sense of
the question Let's uh let's wait a
second we'll jump to one so Jared can
hear it the answer
let me jump let me jump over to one from
some slido and then we'll go back to
Jared okay yep
um but the question was you've got
epidemiologists and biostatisticians in
your organization as in Pharma do you
see any change from those folks using
some I get it some alternative software
to our
that's good right yeah
um I mean
I work in a most mostly python dominated
world I mean most of my colleagues are
python uh python users
there is
from an object oriented programming
perspective
there is a lot that is going on on a
daily basis that they're working on
um which is more like traditional
engineering related not specific to data
science or inference or prediction
um
I am a huge believer that you should use
whatever
um you feel most competent in if you
feel restricted by a certain technology
like if you feel restricted by some
alternative software
um you can you know start exploring r or
python or Julia
um
you know you'd probably want to start
with like whatever is most like closely
aligned with the syntax so that it
doesn't feel like you're having to
you know pull your hair out while you're
trying to work a full business day and
learn a new language
um
but yeah I I'd say SAS comes with a
heavy price tag
um the maybe sooner you can
become comfortable or find a way to
replicate the same type of work with an
open source programming language
you might find yourself able to do
things just as fast and with maybe uh
a more robust like skill side or
capabilities with the language
um
you know to to visualize or iterate or
make predictions
thanks Xavier I'm worried about Jared
now he's not back yet so we'll hold
Jared question
um so I was actually going to try and
figure out how to work this into the
conversation because I love this example
when you share it and somebody asked
anonymously did you create a branded
test shiny app in applying for your
return to sunteam
no I didn't
um luckily I had
several apps in production we were doing
some really neat things
um you know when I was at Health Net we
had several apps that were in production
it got to the point where like
managing some of the pipelines for the
different apps was becoming a bit
of a like of a recurring more time
consuming process the more apps we had
all of a sudden we found ourselves
needing to
continue to streamline like
data integer transformation for some of
these different apps and so we created a
web app updater that was it was itself a
shiny app but also capable of updating
other shiny apps or at least the code
from other shiny apps that kind of stuff
um
you know it's not typical to see that
kind of stuff with shiny apps at least
not the shiny apps I've seen so anyway
where I was going with this the
production team I am now part of or like
the corporate data science team at least
they had some samples to kind of chew
off of of the type of you know our work
that or shiny work that I could do but
that I would say for for organizations
not familiar with
um
you know plotly Dash uh apps or
streamlit apps or you know
shiny apps being able to show them the
speed of
um a web application like shiny
um and how kind of like clean it can
look with an advanced UI
that definitely goes a long way in my
opinion to
um
you know impressing the people that you
were interviewing with
for anybody who didn't see it before
didn't know what that question was
referencing to Javier had shared before
that in an interview with Bloom reach he
created a interactive shiny app that
used their branding and color scheme and
so I just put that into the chat too so
everybody can see the blog post that he
made about that
yeah
um Travis gurkey I don't know if he's on
here today but he had asked if he could
reference this as a cover letter
accessory and one of his uh
our our kind of talks and I was like of
course yeah please do this but at the
time my GitHub repository for it was
just like
you know super high level read me it was
you know oh this is a shiny app that I
styled with Bloom reach theme
um so I I wrote this blog post
um just in an effort for people that are
less familiar with shiny or maybe with r
I tried to write it in a way where
um you know people with basic like get
or GitHub understanding could go in
there and clone the repo and
um you know try and tweak their the app
to their liking to their company
um yeah
I'd love to just put it out there if
anybody else has other apps that you
think would be really helpful to share
with examples like this feel free to put
them into the chat too so we can all see
I love to see all the resources shared
in the chat
I was just going to say Absalon as well
they're a consulting firm data science
consulting firm they make some
incredible shiny apps
um they have some beautiful uh you know
shiny app examples on their Gallery uh
on their you know public facing website
the RS the shiny website itself
um
I I don't know what the new posit link
for it is but that has a bunch of
galleries a bunch of gallery examples on
their Gallery with both like you can go
in there and launch the shiny app you
can also see the source code behind each
and every one of those so that's a good
way to learn too sorry Rachel cut you
off there
no this is your show I want you to see
everything
um I was trying to just share some of
those links into the the chat there too
but Jared I see you're back
can you hear us
yes hopefully I'm not cutting out sorry
the weather here is terrible but no no
worries we can uh we can hear you now
okay short and sweet I wanted to make
sure to not answer your question when
you you dropped off so let's Circle back
to the beginning okay okay so short and
sweet just wanted to get your opinion on
if grad school was the way to go to
getting you
um feeling like you were
um able to open up the doors for more
data science and machine learning type
roles or if kind of having that one-off
background I mean ideally for me it's
like I come from kind of a hybrid I've
got my background is more in public
health Epi but then I do more
programming and uh you know clinical
type work but having that heavy medical
background has always been an asset so I
did know from your background if you
felt that was the the way to get your
feet in the door or if you were more
um
like was it a benefit or do you feel
like you could have got there without I
guess is the short answer
grad school allowed me the time to be
able to
get to where I wanted with like the
basics of data science and programming
um if I was in a full-time job
throughout that time
um
you know what even if I didn't have a
full-time job I think grad school just
gave me sort of a
a set routine for being able to learn
this stuff
I don't actually think you need a
graduate degree to
you know get into this type of work or
you
I lack the discipline to learn all these
topics and Concepts
just on my own
um and for me I found that grad school
really did help just push me to
you know learn
not Python and R more specifically like
to learn about
um the math that underpins a lot of the
data science that we're doing now and
you know how to apply these different
algorithms to business problems that the
way in which grad school sort of force
feeds that information to you
I think the Alternative Learning it on
your own would just be really hard I
don't know that there's any one resource
that
um
and I'm sure there are some great ones
out there I just don't know of any sole
kind of resource that would give you
such like a robust or like holistic
understanding of data science
I hope that answers your question Jared
yeah no I think it really does i i
there's so much to learn and it's kind
of like trying to stay ahead of a movie
train and it it always makes me kind of
curious to know how your um I know it's
not a one size fits all but you're like
the right approach to learning this
versus trying to just ingest such large
amounts you know like consistency like
you said and being kind of being holding
yourself personally accountable to to
train yourself through that but just
knowing and kind of understanding of if
there's a better way
yeah no I I get it
um yeah for me I kind of knew the kinds
of
data science work I wanted to get into I
mean I was doing
I wasn't calling it this but I was doing
time series forecasting that was sort of
my bread and butter in financial
modeling
um and so I knew of all these different
techniques for time series that were
possible
um
I just didn't know how to
you know I didn't know where to start
and so
grad school for me really helped sort of
open the doors of what's possible with
code for
different types of Time series problems
you know
like yeah
I see Hugh you had you had asked a great
question in the chat a bit earlier do
you want to jump in
yeah sure
um I first want to say thank you to
Javier I've been super excited for this
talk
um and he's had very a number of kind
comments on LinkedIn and tests in the
past and I've always been really
appreciative of his willingness to to
engage like that
um so thank you this is awesome
um I wanted to ask uh with you standing
up uh in our group and uh potentially
converting people
um when you're showing somebody R uh for
the first time that they may potentially
move over what are some of the things
that you focus on I.E like the
visualization aspects or the cleaning
transformation side or the modeling
um I know oftentimes it feels like the
consumers of the products are really
excited about the visuals but the
day-to-day people get more excited about
like the quality of life things and and
uh you know the ease of working with
data so uh just curious if you had any
uh insights on that
I mean I think
where I've had the most success is less
so on like the end-end consumers who
might be looking at you know a shiny app
or uh some type of visualization and
more on
the people
generating the numbers or summaries that
might later turn into a visualization or
some type of shiny app and so with that
um where I feel like I've had the most
success
with teams that are using
you know
SAS or Excel
is really with just the data
manipulation capabilities of something
like R
um like firstly the Tidy verse which has
grown so much but the idea of sort of a
unified Syntax for data handling
and just showing them the basics of
d-plier and tidier like this is how you
Group by one or many you know variables
this is how you can do a summation this
is how you create new Columns of sums
here's your summary data this is how you
know using tidier this is how I can
pivot really wide or really long or
maybe you need to do both for a certain
calculation
um
showing them the speed that you know in
which this could be done has always
really impressed people that's where
I've kind of had the most success it's
kind of the the basics of these things
not even the really advanced
you know topics or concepts yeah
awesome thank you yeah the pivoting is
always where people go what for me like
but thank you yeah
thank you another question in the chat I
see is from John do you want to jump in
next
nope not yet so it is you went from
Excel to lead machine learning engineer
can you tell us about the journey
anything you found surprisingly hard or
easy
I had a really good I mean because of
SQL I had a really good understanding of
at least how tabular data could be
joined and the different Transformations
that could be done to these data objects
um I think I would have really struggled
without that kind of like basic
understanding but
having said that I think the parts where
I
really struggled at first
was like function writing function
writing was not intuitive to me
basic function writing was but
in general I found it to be very
complicated
um
and it took a solid I don't know three
to six months of practice to feel
actually comfortable function writing
um
even when I started building shiny apps
you know basic shiny is quite easy but
large functions underpin the entirety of
a shiny app everything you do within
Chinese effectively writing functions
so the process of learning shiny and
becoming more comfortable with shiny was
very difficult and something that just
took a lot of repetitions
but it all sort of played together
because while shiny is you know more
like people think of it more as like a
front end type of system
it did make me a much better programmer
in the way I thought about actual
functions and function writing
um
other things that I found hard
I mean looking back I'm sort of
embarrassed to say this but
reproducibility of machine learning was
not something super intuitive either
like
um
you know being able to reproduce a code
set and get the exact same predictions
every time I wasn't quite sure why this
wasn't working
or how to like create these fixed views
you know setting a seat or whatever you
need to do to
to ensure that someone else Downstream
could replicate your study or analysis
and get the exact same findings
themselves
um
yeah I hope hope that's kind of what you
were looking for John
thanks Xavier and somebody had asked
anonymously on slide out what IDE if any
are you and your colleagues using for
development work or Studio emacs Bim vs
code notepad I think all of the above
honestly
yeah
um I use rstudio every day
um so I'm in the r Studio IDE
um
I seem to be in terminal a lot these
days just you know like the shell
running bash commands and whatnot anyway
um but yeah the r Studio IDE definitely
where I spend most of my time
I know that you are two weeks into this
new role but is there's like if you
think of the next year ahead in this
role what are you most excited about or
what made you most excited about this
role
for me it was more I'm really excited
about the challenge that's going to come
with becoming a better just overall
software engineer or you know become
better at
programming at large not just our
specific
um
I'm like constantly humbled at everyone
I work with
um
just
their breadth of knowledge with all
these different systems
um I've sort of
touched a lot of these different systems
for you know ml Ops or ml engineering
um but being able to really dive deeper
into
some of these platforms to to get
production jobs out of any language I'm
really excited about the challenge there
and and you know the growth and learning
opportunity
thank you so much Javier and I know we
have five minutes left because you do
have a meeting right at the top of the
hour here so I want to make sure that
there weren't questions that I missed
over on slido
or through the chat
I just happened to see a question it
said anyone using vs code for R shiny
I've tried this I still feel like
our studio itself is just like the gem
for coding an R
um but I do really like vs code for
python
thanks heavier this is Daniel I I asked
that question I I asked it because I I
write a lot of R in my position as well
and I write a lot of shiny applications
and I've started to think about vs code
because I write my Python and postgres
in vs code and I would just kind of like
all that to be together but as you
mentioned vs uh you know vs code is not
ideal for our and our studio really is
the best or what was it is the really
the best place for writing our code
these days and just kind of wondering
what where others are in that
no
no I see a few comments in the chat to
Danielle and different perspectives
and
in the minute a few minutes or so we
have left here I know there were a lot
of questions in the beginning and
comments on like Excel and data science
and I was just curious circling back to
that conversation
like what do you think has been
most effective for you at like Bridging
the Gap between those two teams or two
sets of users because I know there are
some people who are probably always
going to stay in Excel but you might
need to work with them as well and what
have you found helpful
like data extract if you're if you're
working at a company that's large enough
where
um it doesn't need to be a large company
but I feel like at larger companies
tapping into databases
um or you actually have databases you're
not just operating in a world where it's
Excel files or CSV files
um
then
showing how you could kind of stay
within the same you know our notebook or
framework from data collection just
pulling it straight into your
environment you know manipulating it
there
you writing it out or summarizing it as
you know an HTML file like knitting an
rmd to an HTML file or
um a flex dashboard or something that's
still static but interactive that has
gone a long way too
um
and the speed of everything like the
speed of the data manipulation and data
handling for millions or tens or
hundreds of millions of rows that always
shocks people because if you've got a
lot of columns in Excel after about I
don't know three four hundred thousand a
rows your Excel is crawling and you can
look at your RAM and it's eating up your
entire available Ram whereas you know
with something like python or R it's
definitely not the case
thank you I I was scrolling the chat and
I see a lot of people weighing in with
comments on talking people out of phds
and suggesting that as a topic idea uh
but Javier before you go I know in the
beginning you also mentioned like one of
the things you like to do for fun is
keeping up to date on everything that's
going on in the data science space and I
was curious if there are other like
resources
um or maybe people you follow or things
that you'd like to share with us all
um
let's see the tidyverse blog in terms of
staying up on news related to tidy
models or tidy verse
um that's great that's one of my
favorite resources
um
the rstudio AI blog or posit AI blog
that's another good one just kind of
looking at the incremental developments
with
um torch which is like native torch for
R and then looking at you know lose
which is sort of like the Keras for
torch that stuff really excites me
um Twitter has been amazing so keeping
up on Twitter with just a lot of the
um are related you know our stats are
shiny or other sort of hashtags like
that
um that's been a great resource the our
bloggers
um or are weekly that's you know our
weekly is a great publication you can
subscribe to their XML
um
and just get like a weekly download of
new packages new updates to existing
packages new tutorials
um Eric Nance runs the
um our weekly podcast
um he's one of the co-hosts there
um yeah there's just a plethora of
resources out there
awesome thank you so much Javier for for
joining us and
sharing your insights this week but also
in other weeks as well when you're on
the audience side I did want to let
everybody know because this comes up
sometimes because there's great comments
and resources in the chat you can save
the chat
um so the little three dots to the right
hand corner if you press that you can
save the chat too
but I will try and group them to share
with the recording when it goes up to
the site as well
thanks Rachel and yeah if anyone wants
to you know contact me feel free to hit
me up on um LinkedIn that's probably the
best place Twitter as well but I use I
don't use Twitter as much
awesome I know you have to jump so no
worries if you have to leave us here I'm
going to share your LinkedIn in the uh
chat as well all right great thank you
so much yeah thank you and hope to see
everybody back next week
um we will be joined next week by JJ
Allaire uh CEO and founder of our studio
now pause it uh maybe he heard that as
he's walking by here but excited to talk
with uh JJ next week as well and that
will be our last hangout for 2022. it's
so nice to see you all this week have a
great rest of the day